So President Joe Biden had his meeting with
Republicans at the White House on Monday night
to talk about the covid relief bill.
Joe Biden had proposed a one point nine dollars
billion package.
Republicans were allowed to express to Joe
Biden why they want a six hundred and eighteen
dollars billion package.
But it's now being made abundantly clear that
Joe Biden and Democrats are hopefully ready
to move ahead without Republicans.
That's what Joe Biden's press secretary, Jen
Psaki, said earlier this week at a White House
press briefing.
It's what Joe Biden seems to be communicating.
And I hope that it's time to just go and do
it, because at this point in time, I don't
see the benefit to anybody in the Democratic
Party.
And that includes Joe Biden as well as Democrats
in the House and Senate of waiting with the
idea that maybe some Republicans might be
OK with some kind of completely flaccid and
pathetic compromise between the one point
nine trillion and the six hundred and eighteen
billion.
And at this point, the perspective should
be if Republicans realize that the one point
nine dollars billion package and what it contains
is popular even with some of their constituents,
it's Republican voters who want the stimulus
package, too.
If some Republicans realize that, then maybe
they'll vote for it in the House or vote for
it in the Senate if they don't realize that
or realize it but don't care.
And every single Republican decides to vote
against the one point nine dollars billion
covid stimulus package, let them do it at
their own peril.
And what I mean by that is once their names
are on the record as saying, no, I'm against
the covid stimulus package that is popular
even with many of my Republican constituents,
well, then it'll be up to Republican voters
to decide whether they want to reelect those
very same Republicans.
And my guess is you will get some Republicans
to come along with Joe Biden's plan because
they realize that many of their constituents
want it.
So Joe Biden has been widely criticized for
sitting down with Republicans on Monday night
and not with Democrats.
Some hot take saying this is a right wing
president.
He talks to Republicans, but not Democrats.
I think that that is very far from what is
going on.
I am pleased, increasingly that Joe Biden
and Democrats aren't budging on the one point
nine dollars billion proposal.
Joe Biden had no need to meet with Democrats
because Joe Biden and Democrats mostly are
on the same page about the one point nine
trillion dollar stimulus package.
Do the meeting with Republicans because Joe
Biden said that he wanted unity.
He said he wanted bipartisanship.
He said he would work with Republicans and
he's trying to add that olive branch was this
meeting on Monday night.
But it's time to stop.
When Joe Biden said if we win these Georgia
races, two thousand dollar checks go out immediately.
That doesn't mean you negotiate with bad faith
actor Republicans into March and hopefully
get checks out by the end of March, if not
early April.
Enough time has gone by.
And if Joe Biden and Democrats don't move
forward on the one point nine trillion, put
it at risk.
You know, if Republicans really want to vote
against that, let them do it.
But if Joe Biden doesn't move forward with
this, it is going to be a failure.
In Joe Biden's column, he was very clear about
what he would do and what it would mean to
add Senate control for Democrats in addition
to Joe Biden taking the White House from Donald
Trump.
And we will now see if they are going to put
their money where their mouths are.
Now, I think that the calculation to be made,
there's a couple of calculations here.
When you think about this from a political
strategy standpoint, Democrats, by not budging
on one point nine trillion, are doing a couple
of different things.
Number one, I hope Democrats and Joe Biden
realize that if you meet somewhere in the
middle, like, imagine that Democrats say,
OK, you know what, we want one point nine
trillion.
Republicans want six hundred and eighteen
billion.
Let's do one point three trillion or something
like that.
A ton of Republicans are still going to vote
against it, even though it will end up likely
passing.
And so Republicans will end up getting the
benefit of it, passing and money getting to
their constituents while continuing to be
able to vertue signal about the debt and the
deficit and spending and what not.
Everybody deserves the money and all of this
sort of stuff.
So the calculation I hope Democrats are making
is they know the plan is more popular with
the country than the portion of people who
voted for Joe Biden.
In other words, this is a covid stimulus package
that's popular with 60, 65, 70 percent of
the country.
That's much more than the share that voted
for Joe Biden.
That means there are millions of Republican
voters that like this plan and they want it
to pass.
If Democrats realize that and they realize
even if.
We negotiate with Republicans, many of them
will still vote against it, let's just move
forward.
We have the ability to do this via budget
reconciliation, assuming all 50 Democrats
in the Senate are on board, which is still
a bit of a question mark, but is likely.
Let's actually put these Republican senators
in particular and members of the House in
a position of having to vote against something
that their constituents want.
Let them vote no.
Let them say it's bad.
Let them then have to go and explain their
votes to their constituents.
I believe this is a political risk very much
worth taking for Joe Biden and Democrats.
I think the meeting was a fine move for Joe
Biden.
He's giving the Republicans an opportunity
to show they actually want to help the American
people.
They present a counter offer that's so pathetic
and pitiful that it's humiliating and embarrassing
and now put them in the position of actually
saying, are you really going to vote for nothing
for your constituents?
Are you going to try to prevent any money
from going out?
Because this is the package.
So I'm fine with the meeting.
I'm fine with not budging.
I'm fine with moving forward without Republicans.
The question now is, can Joe Biden actually
get it done if he can get it done, his early
approval on covid and in general is going
to persist.
It's going to be booted for lack of a better
term if Joe Biden fails to get this done or
something close to it.
Like I think even if Joe Biden did 600 billion
in the end, I think it would be considered
a failure.
He said two thousand dollar checks are going
out now.
We're already talking about adding fourteen
hundred to the six hundred to make it a total
of two thousand.
That's already a concession that I don't like
to see.
If Biden can't get this done and get it done
the next 10 to 14 days, it is going to be
the first major failure of the Biden administration.
Let's hope it doesn't happen.
I remain cautiously optimistic that it will
get done.
I like the way Democrats are just saying it's
one point nine trillion.
That's what it is.
Vote no.
If you want Republicans, I think many will
end up voting for it